severed heads serpent children and a
45-minute battle scene here are a few of
the scenes that were simply too much for
Marvel Phil Coulson may have only been a
secondary character in the main MCU but
he played an important role during the
early stages of the franchise a longtime
Ally of Nick Fury and a leading member
of Shield Clark Greg brought the
character to life on screen in live
action and animated form and continued
to play Coulson and Agents of Shield
even after his apparent death at the
hands of Loki in The Avengers as he
attempts to escape the Helicarrier on
which he has been imprisoned Loki stabs
Coulson from behind with his scepter
this proves to be a pivotal moment in
the movie and the MCU generally
providing the necessary motivation to
force the heroes to form the Avengers
however early versions of the film gave
Coulson a far more gruesome death to
avoid an R rating the filmmakers had to
tone it down considerably with Avengers
Infinity war in full swing the children
of Thanos attack wonder and vision in
Edinburgh in an attempt to capture the
mindset Stone a battle quickly ensues as
several members of The Avengers appear
to help the two Heroes this includes
Captain America Black Widow and the
Falcon the group manages to repel
thanos's minions rescuing wonder and
vision this fight though was originally
set to include another member of The
Avengers in the book Avengers endgame
the art of the movie designer Phil
Saunders explained that the script also
involved James rhods in the dramatic
battle lucky for him he was removed
though because an early version of the
scene had the children of Thanos split
War machine in two eventually the camera
would reveal that Rose was actually
piloting the war machine suit remotely
but that might not have been enough to
lessen the shock of an apparent gruesome
and rather sudden death the writers
ultimately removed the scene as
something similar had happened in an
earlier Iron Man film Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 pushes the envelope in
terms of the kind of content usually
allowed in the MCU the film features
several bloody heart-wrenching deaths
alongside plenty of violence and even
the mcu's first F bomb there's a button
under the handle press that
in okay now what open the door that's
perhaps no surprise however because
James gun Series has always felt a
little more mature than other films in
the franchise despite all that some
scenes were still removed from Guardians
of the Galaxy volume 3 to keep it from
receiving an R rating Chief among them
was a moment with Adam Warlock and his
mother Aisha speaking about the threat
posed by the Guardians of the Galaxy
warlock lets out an angry Tyra telling
Aisha that he will stomp on their skulls
mush their brains urinate on their
bodies and make love to their carcasses
there's no real indication about where
the scene would have taken place
although it looks likely that it may
take place after warlock's initial
attack on nowhere at the start of the
film it's also not clear exactly why gum
removed the rant but it's entirely
possible that Kevin feige in company
thought that Adam's nasty threats were a
step too far Avengers endgame the art of
the movie delves Into the production of
endgame and in inity War the book
contains several stories about moments
that didn't make it into the films or
were ultimately cut from The Script
before shooting began one sequence that
stands out in this regard is the story
of how Thor Rocket and Groot acquire
Stormbreaker author elany russos
explains that originally the trio set
out to retrieve the weapon from the
skull of the gigantic World serpent
rather than have a Tre the dwarf Forge
it for them but stealing Stormbreaker
turns out to be no simple task as saw
and his allies surrounded by the
skeletons are forced to battle and kill
the Serpent's terrifying children to
escape visual development artist Rodney
fenta explained there was also an idea
of how after they got Stormbreaker as
they were escaping the children of the
world serpent would attack them and they
would have to fight their way out the
mcu's television series might seem like
an appropriate place to play with some
more adult content after all the shows
featured on Disney plus don't have to be
submitted to the Motion Picture
Association for ratings and AR
broadcasts on traditional television
networks however that hasn't been the
case so far and it is clear that Disney
wants to keep the MCU shows as
familyfriendly as possible oh this is
going to be a
gas this thinking is evident in the way
that certain content was removed from
moonnight despite some initial teasers
suggesting this series might feature the
mcu's bloodiest fights to date that
didn't turn out to be the case here's an
example in the first episode of the show
Mark Spectre battles one of Arthur
Harrow's demonic Jackal however just as
the action Begins the camera pans to a
hallway leaving it up to the viewers to
imagine what's happening it's a
disappointing anticlimax especially
considering that this moment features
spectre's first onscreen transformation
into his moonnight Persona leaked
footage of rehearsals indicate this was
supposed to be more of a brutal slugfest
one that was apparently too violent for
Disney to stream Marvel's what if series
took the MCU in a slightly different
direction this animated show depicts
alternate takes on established events
with certain characters and history
series changed to show what might have
been one particular episode titled what
if Doctor Strange lost his heart instead
of his hands shows what might have
happened if Christine Palmer had died in
Strange's car crash Doctor Strange sets
out to use the Mystic guards to attempt
to resurrect her but to no avail
throughout the episode strange becomes
more deranged as Christine continues to
die despite his best efforts when he
uses the power of the dark dimension to
Aid his efforts the Ancient One splits
him into two individuals essentially a
good version that accepts his failure
and an evil strange that goes to more
extreme lens eventually the villainous
version absorbs the good strange in the
original script this scene would have
been far more graphic showrunner AC
Bradley wanted the evil strange to beat
the good strange to death using the eye
of aoto until the storyboard artists
toned down the violence a decision with
which Bradley ultimately agreed Avengers
endgame pitted Thanos against almost
every hero who had appeared throughout
the entire MCU franchise up until that
point I am
inevitable in a climactic final battle
Thanos unleashes his true power and
almost kills several important figures
using his strength and fighting ability
to defend himself against all attacks
there isn't much core however even
though the likes of Captain America and
Iron Man certainly take An Almighty
beating speaking to Entertainment Weekly
directors Anthony and Joe Russo
explained how they had planned to make
this battle far more graphic than it
appears in the Final Cut as part of an
original draft of the story the
directors wanted to appear in front of
the assembled Heroes and throw the
decapitated head of an alternate version
of Captain America in front of them
demonstrating just how far he was
willing to go to sub Earth's Mightiest
Heroes Joe Russo said we wanted Thanos
to walk up to the Avengers and throw
Captain America's head on the ground we
couldn't give up on it and finally we
said all right what if we don't do that
can we find another way into the third
act and that's when it turned into what
it is now the Incredible Hulk was
released in 2008 not long after the
first Iron Man yeah yet the MCU second
installment has always marked an outlier
in terms of its tone as well as the fact
that Edward Norton played Bruce Banner
rather than Mark Ruff The Story begins
with Bruce's transformation into the
Hulk after he is exposed to gamma
radiation as part of a super soldier
program led by General thadius Ross the
movie then jumps ahead years later with
Bruce hiding in Brazil to evade Ross and
the US military well the Incredible Hulk
is a darker film compared to the rest of
the MCU the writers wanted to push this
even further during the early stages of
development in the book The Making of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Marvel
studios's executive Steven brussard
details an alternative opening for the
movie that saw Bruce tried to end his
life in the Arctic suicide is a
difficult topic to cover sensitively of
course and having an important hero
attempt to kill himself right at the
start of a film may have been too much
for Marvel Executives especially in the
early stages of an ambitious new
franchise this deleted scene is briefly
alluded to in The Avengers however in
which Banner mentions a swar suicide
attempt during an argument with the
other Avengers I got
low I didn't see an end so I put a
bullet in my mouth and the other guy
spit it out at the start of Avengers
Infinity War Thanos already possesses
the Power Stone this destructive
artifact was last seen in the MCU during
the events of Guardians of the Galaxy
when the heroes left it in the care of
xandarian officials during a later
conversation Thor confirms that Thanos
decimated zandar to capture the Power
Stone but the actual battle is not shown
in an interview of the web series near
mint condition Comics writer and
thanos's Creator Jim Stalin revealed
that this was not always the plan in
fact the Russo Brothers apparently
filmed a 45-minute sequence to appear at
the start of the film depicting thanos's
assault on Xander Stalin said there was
a whole sequence of him getting the
first Gem and they had to cut that out
they shot it but they never wanted to
spend the money on the effects and they
didn't want the movie to be as long as
the second one was alas fans may never
get to see the fall of xandar in all it
Glory of all the films in the MCU so far
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness is the closest to Series has
come to an R-rated movie some Ry
schlocky demon Fest features plenty of
horror elements and graphic violence
especially in moments with a Scarlet wit
uses her full Powers against her enemies
but one deleted scene in particular
would have made things even more
gruesome the scene in question involves
wonderer fighting the Sorcerers of
kamatash fight coordinator leang yangang
posted footage on his social media
showing rehearsal SS for a far more
violent battle in the video the Skarlet
witch can be seen killing her opponents
in much more horrifying and bloody ways
as the Avenger turned villain fully
Embraces her evil side perhaps the most
shocking moment however was to occur at
the beginning of the battle to show her
threats are serious Wonder tus as Baron
mordo severed head at Doctor Strange no
doubt Multiverse of Madness was a
gruesome movie but this would certainly
have taken it over the line Thor love
and thunder could have been a lot darker
than it was Christian Bale who portrayed
the villainous Gore told inverse that he
and director Tao yti wanted to push the
limits as much as possible on the movie
even when they knew the action was
unlikely to ever make it onto the screen
oh God you will die in some instances
even fellow co-star Chris Hemsworth
thought they were going too far and
worried that the scenes would only be
appropriate for an R-rated release
however Bale and yti wanted to explore
as many possibilities as possible
although it isn't clear exactly what
these particular scenes might have been
there is certainly little chance anyone
will ever get to see them Bale said
Chris Hemsworth a couple of times he
looked at me it was like dude that's a
little too far but it was a great joy to
give it a
shot